what did the Romans do to democracy my
friends what did they do they abolished
it in favor of a dictatorship and then
the imperial system and why were the
work Romans not much good at drama
why were they much interested in drama
whether tragic or comic because
fundamentally the whole audience was
forever being dragged off to another
entertainment the games and watching
people and animals being slaughtered in
a depraved ritual that was endemic in
the Roman world and virtually absent
from Greece how many people died in that
building that is emblematic still a
Roman culture and civilization that the
Colosseum how many people were killed in
it probably 200,000 the Greek liked the
happy release of the theater the roman
idea of good family entertainment was
cutting the feet of some poor fief
coating his stumps with honey and
letting the Bears do the rest I'm afraid
that in many ways the Romans were
bastards so ripped and brutalized as
children that they liked to inflict pain
themselves what's the most famous image
from all the frescoes of Pompeii it's at
one of the women whipping each other
what happens in Florence in terrorists
instead of jokes people have pulled off
to be flogged it was a society not based
on democracy but on fear